was geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einem weiteren video hier auf einem
channel ich hoffe euch geht es gut wir
machen heute den zweiten part ich bin
immer noch in dortmund ihr habt sicher
schon im ersten part gesehen dort ging
es um das beste essen ich besuche
verschiedene youtuber in verschiedenen
städten und wir bestellen einmal das
festessen oder schlechtes essen heute
bin ich beim felix wieder und schlechtes
essen hast du wahrscheinlich kein
plattform das beste essen durftest du
dir ja quasi aussuchen und deswegen
schauen wir erstmal was ist hier denn es
wirklich schlecht es gibt man muss sagen
dort und hier felix superschöne wo ich
fühle mich hier richtig wohl und ich
habe jetzt denke ich habe jetzt richtig
lust mit dir hier was leckeres zu essen
oder vielleicht auch nicht an die leute
die nicht wissen wie felix aussieht
jeder flex ist jetzt geschehen kommentar
erlebt ja auch noch werdet ihr an osm
von michael ballack kommt was gut ist so
felix dann würde ich sagen machen wir
uns jetzt mal ans bestellen ich habe
extra schon sonst tief von dir
ausgesucht ich muss sagen bei die hier
in dortmund es gibt wirklich nur wenig
sachen die super schlecht sind aber eine
sache ist herausgestochen sie haben
gerade mal 15 bewertungen und haben
jetzt schon nur drei sternen ja ich
nehme mich richtig aus nein das ist ja
nicht gut es ist schon aus 15.3 stelle
das ist unterirdisch deswegen wenn ich
mal geförderte uns hier jetzt erwartet
so darfst du natürlich außen was immer
man möchte ja also die machen halt
amerikanische pizza und burger der
schritt den wir alle für ist keine pizza
hat nie gerne unter unterwegs sind in
die weltspitze ist versteht dass nicht
er das liegt daran weil ich pizza als
nicht besonders an sehr leckere geile
pizza ist was anderes aber so eine
standard pizza ich hasse es auch pizza
zu bestellen irgendwie hauptsatzung von
einer pizzeria ist so meine
lieblingsbücher da wird klar dass also
das ausweisen
neuenhaus gerät alles was du willst
schreibe ich jetzt ist der kleine freund
also spannende auch so viele stellen wie
ich möchte wirklich jetzt wirkt euro
auch wenn du das auf ist natürlich will
man so ein cooles gericht bestellten
sich samstagabend so bestellte mir
verkauft oder sowas drei sterne 15
erwartet den laden noch eine chance
geben fehler die kombination war halb
verbrannt und die soße das bisschen was
worden war war geschmacklos mastix waren
knochenhart und ausgelaugt er bestellt
auch mozzarella sticks beim lieferdienst
nicht so gepasst hatte mich hamburger
passt ja okay was möchte für eine ich
muss sagen wo es aber auch echt ne
schöne küche hier hast du nicht war über
nacht für nacht koch wieder zu machen
mit dem sie anbieten nicht mehr hier
sein schnitzel die nun habe ich euch die
angesprochen ich etwas anderes was meint
ihr das nicht wollt ja aber nehmt ihr
euch kennen die doch schon mal dazu er
war somit krise ja ja das klappt
überhaupt kein problem
so eine idee ist der geilste was mit
mexikanischer so schwer vorgestellt ja
ich bin gespannt das ding ist das teil
leister irgendwas mit american und ich
mache ein schnitzel und komische ja aber
egal okay dann würde ich sagen für mich
gibt es dann noch hatte burger bestimmt
ne ne die beliebten gerichte mississippi
berger soll ich den namen machen erst
dann kommt der nächste city berger und
dann würde ich trotzdem hier noch seine
pizza nehmen so wie heute ist irgendwie
schmeckt etwas möchte für eine im x raid
einfach mal da kann man ja viel verkehrt
machen viel verkehrt machen jaja so okay
dann haben wir's bestellbar und ich bin
mal gespannt leute was mir so warum
kommt der betrag mindestbestellwert zu
erreichen kredit noch müsste noch mal
trinken wasser oder so april 12 heute
samstag leute da kann ich hier ein rein
saugen weitere fußballer eben das kauf
wie das noch alle trinken pro abend ein
bier- oder auf 291 wo bist du
leute essen ist bestellt kommt
allerdings erst in zweieinhalb stunden
ist egal dann sehen wir uns habe ich
noch nicht so gross nun ja ich bin
wirklich mal gespannt was da ankommt bis
gleich leute das geht das essen ist mit
45 minütiger verspätung dann auch doch
noch eingetroffenen wir waren uns sicher
es kommt einfach nicht mehr du kannst ja
auch nicht anrufen und so und es ist
auch schon aufgefallen die pizza des
pizzaboten noch bestellt die wurden
vergessen dann lass uns doch jetzt mal
starten und hier richtig beim auspacken
ich möchte bitte dass du anfängst mit
deinem schnitzel bitte doch unfähig ein
bürger am thema pommes waren dabei als
die haben gar keine post eingestellt
oder eigentlich würde ich mal eine pizza
pommes vertauschen nehme ich das machen
kann es dabei gehen wir bei den
bürgermeisterwahlen form ist bei das
lustige bei diesen lieferando lehnen die
direkt so übels untergehen ich hab das
mal beobachtete ist in zwei wochen
wieder zu theoretisch das kann ja jeder
du kannst jetzt auch hingehen du hast
gar kein restaurant aber du kannst bei
lieferando durch anmelden und dann
kochen möchte ich klar du brauchst du
eine genehmigung so aber das ist glaube
ich relativ easy umzusetzen dann fangen
woher ich weiß ob man sieht so richtig
was das ist kummer wir haben hier ja ein
burger tiefkühl partie das kannst du
richtig sehen zwei tomatenscheiben
darauf eine gurke bisschen salat und
haben wir hier so ist das bei sami
pressing ja dann auch diese fertig soße
vom supermarkt dass sich leute wirklich
denken das funktioniert und welche was
das ist wirklich krass ja also wir
wollen ja gar nichts drunter machen aber
das ist ja wirklich so unterstütze jetzt
warm up zum teil
mach mal auf ist doch kein schnitzel na
gut vielleicht ist das halt mit der
mexikanischen links punkt weist das dort
ist ja die mexikanische geht natürlich
steckt das ist einfach komplett
fertiggestellt nein nein nein warte kurz
darunter wird sich der schütze verbergen
ich sags ja wir haben bestellt dass
fritzl mexikaner mit pommes frittes das
heißt sie kommen es gehören zu der schau
mal das passt nämlich auch das ist
nämlich das schnitzel mit mexikanischer
soße das ist sowas wie chili con carne
darüber ja dann probiert es doch mal
felix die pommes gehören auch noch dazu
die sehr gläubig sind okay das kann
passieren wenn man liefert ich versuche
das war möglichst locker zu sehen weil
man muss es respektieren das ist essen
und ich werde es probieren hier haben
wir dann die amerikanische pizza die
ganz gut aussieht aber halt keine
american pizza ganz klar sondern einfach
nur eine standard wobei die ist schon
ein bisschen ja jetzt schon ein bisschen
dicker aber trotzdem weiß nicht so ganz
dann lasst uns machen am start ist
ich fange erst mal mit dem entspannt ist
ein anderer das ist die pizza also
wollte ich muss wirklich sagen ich habe
schon viel aus schlechtes essen bestellt
aber das ist schon echt bis auf die
pizza krass war auch die pizza dieser
käse der ist so richtig fest sondern
bildet alles einmal durch jetzt hier
auch daran dass ist so richtig dass fett
ist hier so richtig rein gelaufen
das ist mir fällt das wegstecken
nach dem laufen perfekt also sie
schmeckt auf jeden fall nicht gut aber
sie schmeckt besser als ich gedacht
hätte und man kann sie das
na ja das stimmt für mexiko
das ist wirklich eine herausforderung
für mich weil ich erst so zwar hin und
wieder fleisch aber ich es will halt
richtig gute qualität sein ich es auch
eigentlich nur als egal was jetzt ein
exkurs mussten ich kann das eigentlich
will ich
habe das schnitzel nicht bestellt das
hast du gestellt der burger ich habe in
meinem leben noch nie so einen
schlechten bürger gesehen ein hallenbad
city besser ich war mal im schlechtesten
bürgerladen in köln dieser burger laden
war eine rein zu vollkatastrophe und
nicht mal dieser bürger so schlimm aus
fatih zum schnitzel es ist ganz ganz
weit entfernt von einem schnitzel was
ich essen würde das auf jeden fall als
schmeckt halt überhaupt nicht sagt ich
es ist brutal trocken war diese soße ist
da drüber und die macht das ganze
vielleicht ein bisschen saftige aber du
merkst du das ist so gruselig vielleicht
aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen wie es
war würde das im leben nicht essen ist
es vielleicht hart aber das kann man
nicht essen die hier noch einmal der
bürger weiß nicht ob es auf der kamera
so gut rüber kommt muss auch sagen diese
kamera macht alles sehr schön das ist
der schlimmste bürger den ich je gesehen
habe kannst du bitte einmal die pommes
probieren wenigstens du bist so leicht
du kannst doch bitte jetzt einfach eine
pommes essen ich und mir sagen wie die
ist das deswegen lächerlich und zwei
hinter
japan extrem labbrig kann man aber essen
ich hatte ja wirklich auch hin und
wieder schon mal schlechte restaurants
damals die aber gar nicht so schlecht
waren aber das ist wirklich das ist eine
rein zu vollkatastrophe also es tut mir
leid dass es so schnell passiert zudem
es gibt bekommt gekochten gebracht hat
meint wenigen wirklich dass wir nun also
das ist so schmeckt
einfach von diego hier richtig machen
ich weiß nicht was diesen vielleicht
denkt er wirklich das ist gut ist oder
keine ahnung aber das war wirklich mir
fehlen die worte 23 euro mir fehlen
wirklich für dieses essen die worte es
fehlt was es war viel zu spät und es ist
eine reise zumutung leute nehmt uns das
nicht übel wenn wir da jetzt so drüber
hergezogen habe aber es ist einfach die
wahrheit das war ein griff ins klo
wortwörtlich trotzdem vielen dank fürs
zuschauen aber jetzt sagen den kanal
checkfelix aus auch wenn der nicht
gewährt sehr viel probieren das war's